tu avais déjà fait les photos un petit
peu dénudée vous franchement ou est ce
qu on vous en a demandé on a été
chercher des photos les plus sexy des
chroniqueurs à regarder par exemple
géraldine maillet regardez vous même
votre photo la plus sexy gerald in salah
nouveau record à wayne obama mais c'est
exceptionnel pour mister suisse
non monsieur c'est magnifique thieves
est tué bravo c est pour l'a 20 jours
c'était quoi le bac français
le père français le voc je croyais le
beurre français le créole français c'est
magnifique à regarder
on a également maxime gagné votre photo
la plus regardée maxime guen ita ian
khama est la plus sexy
c'est quoi cette connerie ah oui c'est
ça isabelle isabelle regarder mes
témoins les photos les michael on passe
vite à avoir été dans ce cas peut pas
être et voir vous avez vous aviez l'air
ora sera vous aviez raté le permis ou un
non je ne vais sortir d'une dispute avec
mon mari ou un très bon démarrage coûté
beaucoup il est marié à sa fin avec la
photo en couleur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mettez moi jusqu'à +1 si on va pas
toutes les perles et oui ah bon en effet
nommé ya rien du tout linder à layrac à
une épaule il ya une épaule tatum à mon
épaule et à une latitude et le regard
mais la figure et regarde tout ce que
vous voulez dire par là bas ça vous dit
une invitation c'est oui ont vocation
c'est c'est magnifique
j'avais leur l'applaudît viendra j'en
attends c'est pas une habitation de bar
mitzvah une invitation au petit déjeuner
regardez c est l'amérique aurait vidé
retory par isabelle on peut pas être
trop belle ola au et mathieu mathieu
aussi limitation évaluons dit que
j'aimerais être pas que le rebord de la
piscine
c'est là
non